I never played the original Lords of the
Fallen when it released back in 2014 I
wasn't even playing any Souls games back
then but apparently I didn't miss much
the community memd on the game back then
for its clunky or heavy feeling gameplay
that most Gamers back then obviously did
not enjoy since then this game has faced
quite the development Journey shifting
between Studios and eventually being put
on hold as a mere concept for a couple
of years it wasn't until hexor Studio
stepped in to take on the project
initially they were faced with the
daunting challenge of creating a game
that virtually nobody was interested in
Lords of the fallen 2 however as time
passed they made the Bold decision to
not pursue a sequel or a remake but
instead embarked on a full reboot of the
original the trailer they released last
year was incredibly impressive and it
guarded widespread attention and
excitement mainly because it looked
nothing like the original aside from the
name of it of course every everyone was
eagerly anticipating the releasee of
another game in the soulslike genre
especially considering that many gamers
had just recently hopped off the Elden
ring hype train at the time apparently
this Lords of the Fallen was basically
using all of the same lore and Dark
Fantasy World traits of the original
while bringing in a few new gameplay
ideas to build off of after clocking in
about 25 hours and completing the game I
don't know how to feel other than mixed
on Lords of the Fallen honestly I didn't
have have that much fun playing this
game artistically this game is pretty
it's a good look game and the art
Direction utilizes the new Unreal Engine
5 to its full capabilities there's not
an inch of this game's world that isn't
detailed from its vast Landscapes and
beautiful architecture they basically
had to design Two Worlds in one
throughout the entire game since the
player can willingly peer through and
walk through the realm of the living and
the dead being able to develop something
like this could not have been easy it's
a unique gameplay mechanic mechanic that
can be considered honestly a technical
Marvel and is the main difference
between the original and this reboot
needless to say I had many moments
throughout my playthrough where I had to
stop and look at the beautiful art
Direction I was experiencing it's
amazing looking however this is pretty
much where my pros of the game begin and
end I shouldn't say that quite yet
because I did find the combat in game
play to be somewhat fun at times but was
ultimately outweighed by to put it
bluntly Jank [__] my biggest gripe
with Lords of the Fallen is the level
design every single level in this game
never failed to just confuse me with its
Labyrinth of doors ladders staircases
and dead ends that just don't look or
feel like they should be dead ends
especially when you're required at
points to switch between worlds that can
change the layout of a level completely
I would find myself getting lost on a
regular basis it's possible that some
may enjoy this aspect as it leads to a
bunch of time being allocated to just
exploring every inch of every level but
for me it just felt frustrating this
frustration could be due to the insane
level of complexity of just getting any
progress through each level from its
sparse amount of checkpoints that just
lead to annoying runbacks to where you
just died in hopes of finding a shortcut
that'll make that next run back easier
in regards to the combat it's it's fine
it's okay obviously it's going to feel
familiar to those who played any other
game in the souls like genre but for me
because of my experience with Souls
games this game's combat just felt like
a worse version there's just something
missing here whether it's the animations
or audio design I'd say the issues I
have lean way more toward the audio
design just being not not very good
there were so many moments during combat
cutcenes or just running around where I
noticed a lack of audio not just poor
quality audio sound effects but just a
complete lack of any sound at all it
works the combat is functional obviously
except for the camera I think the camera
needs a complete overhaul it feels just
as weighty as your attacks and movement
do because it feels like whenever you
dodge roll or go from locking on to one
enemy to the next it lags behind a
little bit too much to a point where
it's noticeably annoying for me enemy
design is just lacking you'll be
fighting the same looking enemies 30
hours in as you were in your first hour
it seems the difficulty of enemies and
frankly the difficulty overall in the
game is just from how many worthless two
or three hit enemies they just jamack or
spawn into these levels the encounters
with these enemies also seem to be
placed and programmed in ways to be just
as annoying as possible tight corridors
with multiple enemies hiding behind
boxes with long range enemies way out in
the distance shooting tracking arrows or
whatever at you while a dog sprays fire
at the same time then later on they just
use all of these same enemies in
different levels and raise their health
bar substantially the bosses are not
just disappointing but are downright bad
aside from some interesting spectacle
bosses that have different issues apart
from its design like I said this game is
stunningly atmospheric and the bosses
are no exception to this but it's when
you're actually playing in this
beautiful world and fighting these
bosses that you'll start to notice all
of these annoying flaws I'm using the
word annoying pretty often in this video
because it just perfectly illustrates my
feelings on this game I'm sure I'll use
it in the title or thumbnail the bosses
have insanely telegraphed and limited
move sets that after just a couple of
attempts you'll look like a god gamer to
anyone oblivious to how easy these
bosses can be there's also a lack of
story context with these bosses where it
feels as though the developers just
slapped the boss on a small Bridge or in
a dark room to fill up time and space
just for them to put these bosses as
regular enemies in the next area or
sometimes in the same level you fought
them in I also really dislike the way
they provide some lore beats for the
main bosses where you'll see a ghostly
figure and you'll use your lamp to get a
still ghostly frame of an event that
happened in this area or some dialogue
that I just simply did not care about I
feel like I need to calm down here and
and mention that I don't think Lords of
the Fallen is a bad game there's
definitely some charm to this game that
had me coming back to it on a daily
basis until I beat it I could be wrong
here but there are some major Vibes of
Dark Souls 2 in this game that I just
couldn't shake for my entire playthrough
so if you enjoyed DS2 you'll definitely
like this game developing a great Souls
light game has got to feel like an
almost impossible task when you're
guaranteed to be compared to games
developed by from software who invented
the genre altogether that raises the the
bar of what is expected from your game
and while I think hex works just didn't
quite hit the mark they were going for
with this game this is not a bad game
and could be worth checking out for
yourself it's just a game I did not
enjoy playing plain and simple the story
for Lords of the Fallen is honestly
there's not much going on here for me
the game is set a thousand years after
the events of the original and takes
place in more instead after defeating
the demon god a deer all those years ago
the land is threatened by his return
five beacons of radiant light have kept
a deer at Bay all this time but his
followers have seemingly corrupted the
light marking the inevitability of the
demon God's return it is your job as a
lamp Bearer to travel to all of these
corrupted beams of light and restore
these beacons to their original holy
Radiance the story here isn't exactly
obscure how Souls likes usually are
where you'll feel confused at first and
eventually after mixing and matching
some sto story and lore beats together
you start to understand what the hell is
going on in Lords of the Fallen I really
don't know what's going on at any point
there's plenty of dialogue to listen to
and item descriptions to read but
honestly I would just stop listening
when it felt like these characters were
just saying confusing fantasy mumbo
jumbo word vomit to sound profound when
it really isn't I see red beacons in the
sky and I know I'm supposed to turn them
white that's it however none of the NPC
characters in your Hub area really seem
to even give a [__] about how you're
progressing their dialogue doesn't
change based on where you've been the
bosses you've defeated or the amount of
beacons you've cleansed I'd constantly
visit the main guy who bestowed on us
this incredible task of cleansing the
beacons to see if he had anything to add
each time I defeated a boss or lit up a
beacon to be met with nothing different
just the exact same dialogue as he had
when I first met him some characters do
have interesting things to add to the
story and their own interpretations of
the world around us and them but for the
most part I found the NPCs to be majorly
lacking their voice acted well enough
although the best way I can describe it
is that it feels like I'm listening to a
play unfold rather than having a
conversation with someone it feels like
some of the voice actors are just trying
to hard to sound malevolent or fantasy
likee if that makes sense the narrative
doesn't ever make me feel like I'm doing
anything in its world I'm just running
to Red beacons and when I light them up
it doesn't feel like I made any major
impact on the world or the narrative
since nobody that I'm supposed to talk
to especially in the hub areas they just
don't seem to care so it doesn't ever
feel like I need to be doing any of the
things I am doing there's no sense of
urgency no Stakes I don't know who this
crazy demon god a deer is and the game
never really does a good job of giving
me any information on him what was this
world like during the Thousand Years of
prosperity what exactly am I fighting
for I just never got a feeling of
influential purpose in this game I knew
my objective but that was really it I
want to mention the bosses again and how
lacking they can really be I'm only
going to be showing a few of the first
bosses in the early stages of the game
so I don't spoil too much for you if you
are interested in playing it's not like
I'm gassing up this game for you to go
buy it anyway but I think enough is here
for those who can look past the annoying
aspects of the game that I just couldn't
not everyone feels or thinks the same
when it comes to games so i' never say
no one should ever play this game
because I hate it that's not what I'm
trying to do here but the bosses of
souls games are really the major reason
that I personally play these games and
Lords of the Fallin bosses are just
they're just not compelling they are
disappointing easier than the levels
that lead up to them and most of them
require you to stand around and and wait
and I mean that in a literal sense as
the bosses will just run around or do an
attack that you have to run away from
and requires you to either be waiting
for them to come back and fight you or
you running back to them this isn't the
case for every boss but for a vast
majority of the game My disappointment
in the boss has never changed back to
some positives I really like the rally
system in Lords of the fallen and how it
works with the withering mechanic along
with blocking and parrying one negative
really quick along with these positives
is just how unsatisfying the parrying or
deflecting or whatever you want to call
it feels in this game again this is
mainly because of the sound it makes
when you pull off a successful
Parry the sound is just I don't know
lame weak pitiful all of these words
work apparently they didn't even have a
sound for parrying until right before
release which is just baffling to me but
as for the health system and blocking
incoming damage to create wither which
is indicated by the white section of
your red health bar and being able to
Rally or regain that Health back by
staying aggressive and attacking enemies
is really well done you could just block
forever as long as you're successfully
blocking you'll never die but any attack
that you don't block will ultimately
take away all of that white with Health
all at once so there's some challenge to
this system some Stakes to the rhythm of
blocking attacking playing aggressive or
passive at certain moments this part of
the game was interesting for me and it's
a good Innovation on the rally system
we've come to know from bloodborn and
more recently lies a p i also enjoyed
how casting spells and using items Works
in Lords of the Fallen you map a spell
or item to a particular button input
which is actually a pretty old school
way of doing it but it definitely works
here most Souls games you have to scroll
using the d-pad to a spell or an item
you want to use which has never felt
quite right but here it's just to press
of a button bound to a single trigger
that prompts you with whatever button
you decide to map to for a particular
spell or item it's perfect I honestly
can't see that system being done in a
better way and Future Souls like games
and souls Games should use this exact
system it's much more satisfying than
scrolling till you find it as for any
positives I have on this game that's
that's pretty much all I've got to say I
desperately want to like Lords of the
Fallen but it's the first game all year
that's actively annoyed me I love the
souls like genre more than any other but
this game just isn't it for me like I
said you could like it because there is
a certain charm that kept me coming back
to it but I'd play it for a while and
just get annoyed stop playing think
about it a little bit later hop on again
get annoyed and then get off the game
again I had the same feeling when I
played Dark Souls 2 I don't think it's a
bad game but it's the version of the
souls games I enjoy the least so if you
like DS2 you you're definitely going to
like Lords of the Fallen that's all I've
got to say for today I was planning on
doing a full-blown critique video for
this game just like I did with Liza P
but just for me I don't enjoy it enough
to keep playing it more than one time
which I definitely feel like I have to
do if I'm making a full-blown video on
it I've beaten Liza four times and I
could honestly keep playing it if other
games weren't coming out for me to play
and make content for so I thought I'd
make a video like this one for Lords of
the Fallen thanks for watching guys and
I'll see you all in the next video take
care